the cat but we are indeed with a very
happy victor of the round there is
jeffrey sean jeffrey first of all
welcome back to the studio you started
off blazing hot two victories after that
you cooled off with two losses with the
white pieces how would you assess your
tournament up to this point yeah i mean
it kind of seems like i didn't ever
fully recover from the
from the round three uh loss because
yeah at some point i was really
feeling quite good during that game and
all of a sudden he turned the tables and
uh i mean i ended up losing so
yeah it's been a really difficult event
for me but uh just hoping to finish on a
good note well definitely a good note
was today let's look at that game and
see how you finished your opponent off
yeah where was it felt like his position
got bad and bad and bad and bad but i
couldn't really figure out where it
started getting bad
well first of all i think this g4 i mean
i know it's an idea but
it felt a little bit
more risky for him because he can never
really castle long that's the main issue
because i'm going to hit him with b5 b4
and then in general when i put 9 on e6
it's hard for me to imagine
uh his attack really getting going
right and after g4 knight e6 f3 b5 it it
seemed like e4 actually made your life a
little bit easier allowing you to get to
that king on e1 uh yeah it's a fair
point but on the other hand i'm not sure
what else to suggest for him because he
can play you know something quiet like
bishop too sorry about that maybe king
after no king have two just loses yeah
king of two just loses i'm trying to get
the king to g2 but yeah i mean in
general his king's never gonna find
safety anywhere right so
i think at this point he should just try
to follow his plan
but after e4 i was actually expecting
him to take with the knight
right 94. i thought this was his idea
and i would go bishop seven and then
i
one critical line i think is if he takes
everything on f6 and tries to take on c6
because okay this gets kind of uh
concrete
i don't really want to play bishop a6
um so i was trying to calculate bishop
d7 i think
bishop t7 looks very tempting the idea
yeah queen of three lancaster wasn't
sure but knight d4
defense both
but you got this very cool knight d4
let's put that on the board i wasn't
sure about it but
it's a funny position huh yeah because
i've got rook 88 as also
coming fast so maybe it's just good for
me
yeah
as well which way
sure
the thing is even this position right
right like if i want to at the very
least but it's this might just be
totally lost right i don't think you're
stopping queen h4 yeah
oh
yeah yeah it should be queen before okay
okay yeah yeah it should be yes
so so yeah maybe if this doesn't work
for him then um he has to try
instead of um okay he can't take
everything on f6 i guess maybe bishop
okay i'm definitely better like if
bishop f2 i can you know play knight to
five or something right it's still yeah
this long-term issue with white's king i
think
yeah
at the very least does not look like a
pretty um
position for the white side but better
than taking with the pawn i think
because it did seem that at this point
his position
it really starts to collapse i think he
did play resourcefully like he's he made
it tough for me to get in c5 initially
like if we uh continue on
yeah [ __ ] before i think he has to go
and then yeah i believe what i did was
correct but maybe there are alternatives
also yeah this
yeah so now there are some interesting
lines um so my main point is after d5
so i have two options
i think queen e5 bishop h7 gets messy
though so i'm not sure about this like
king h86
but uh i was planning b3 which i think
he
was afraid of this
and he has i think he has to go to b1
yeah you need to keep an eye on this
bishop right because of queen e5 you
need to be defending the the bishop and
you also need a diagonal tempo yeah
exactly so now uh
i think i
my day was knight d4 because queen e5
bishop g3 so yeah knight d4
and then
so okay the main point is let's say he
takes with the bishop on d4 plays d6
yeah i take he takes
and the funny thing is i might even just
play move like queen b8 because the
knight on a4 was trapped
at the very least so i i'm sure that i'm
getting back the material and then
his his rooks are disgusting it really
does not look like white surviving this
yeah right all right
instead he played rook c1
yeah i think ruxin was a good try
and then i yeah i like bishop c6
so now again b3 is threatened but i
thought here he had to try g5 whether or
not it worked or not just to go for it
because
what he wants is if i go b3
queen b1 i'm not actually that happy to
to take this knight because he goes gh
and then i don't know maybe
now i think he's he's fighting somehow
so
it could be also a little bit of smoke
no
yeah maybe but
some d5 coming that night yeah if okay
if i can go bishop c6 then then he and
it works then he's like d5 yeah i i was
assuming that maybe d5
yeah d5 and you have to do something
like 95
right right but maybe it does get a bit
messy i don't want to give up the bishop
though why am i giving up material what
if i just go back
it should be fine yeah that's like i
want to see if white has some stuff
actually yeah i wanted yeah i wanted
something with
richie wonder i don't know
yeah rook g1 but i can take this guy
right
start simplifying the position take six
yeah it should be yeah okay
it should be it should be winning but
maybe
it's messy right yeah
so he played b3 and it seemed like after
that there was just no way back for him
right right here after queenston it's
very clear-cut yeah
yeah and then this position
it's just over uh well nice bounce back
i'm sure that we were looking forward to
that win uh eluding you for a few rounds
you're a one point away or we expect you
to be one point away from the leaders
going into the last round going all out
uh you're in fact playing one of the
leaders
bro uh wait so uh sam's winning
completely yes and we can pull up that
game uh i assume this is winning let me
see what's going on uh white has again
one of those positions where white has a
horse
the opponent does not have a horse and
that's how we evaluate this one
that's a full piece that's a full piece
right yeah
i mean there will be some technical
issues to convert but
i'm not even sure you have any technical
issues to convert sure yeah yeah
this is
straightforward well jeffrey thank you
for joining us here at the studio we'll
let you guys tomorrow's an early round
and i am sure you are looking forward to
it
yeah it should be an exciting finish
thanks thank you jeffrey all right let's